imagínate que tengo a un conjunto a con
en elementos estos elementos son a 1 a 2
y así hasta a en y bueno voy a suponer
también que este conjunto a es una base
del psuv espacio ver y bueno lo que
quiero enseñarte en este vídeo es que si
a es una base del conjunto b y tiene en
elementos entonces cualquier otro
conjunto que generen al sub espacio 20
debe de tener al menos en elementos
déjame escribirlo aquí cualquier
conjunto que genere debe de tener al
menos n elementos debe tener al menos en
elementos muy bien ya que quiero llegar
con todo esto aquí si tenemos un
conjunto de vectores que generan a su
espacio ven debe tener al menos en
elementos o más en elementos porque yo
sé que esta base debe tiene en elementos
muy bien y cómo lo vamos a demostrar
pues vamos a demostrar por contradicción
es decir vamos a tomarnos uno
que tengan menos de en elementos y nos
vamos a dar cuenta de que no puede
generar al sub espacio bien así que
tomen unos a este nuevo conjunto el
conjunto b1 b2 b3 así hasta bm este base
del conjunto ven y ojo le voy a pedir
que me sea menor que en precisamente es
lo que quiero un conjunto que tenga
menos elementos y bueno como queremos
crear una contradicción entonces vamos a
suponer que este conjunto también genera
el sub espacio ven esto es muy
importante porque justo por aquí va a
caer nuestra contradicción y entonces en
este momento tú te pones a pensar y a
decir oye sal pero esta oración de verde
me está diciendo algo completamente
distinto a lo que me estás diciendo aquí
abajo como puede ser esto cierto
entonces vamos a pensar en cómo crear la
contradicción y para esto déjame crear
un nuevo conjunto el conjunto de uno
prima este conjunto de uno prima poco a
poco te vas a ir dando cuenta porque lo
estoy creando así va a ser igual al
conjunto b pero le voy a agregar a uno
es decir me va a quedar a uno y todos
los demás que tenía en vez de uno
2 así hasta bm date cuenta que aquí
tenemos ya un vector de más y por lo
tanto este conjunto que tengo aquí es
linealmente dependiente esto es muy
importante que te des cuenta este
conjunto que tengo aquí es linealmente
dependiente porque aquí tengo a a1 que
por cierto es muy importante también que
te des cuenta que a uno existe en el sub
espacio ven y déjame ponerlo por aquí
porque es bastante importante aún no
existe en b y es que este vector aún no
sabemos que existen bien porque tenemos
aquí una base debe y por lo tanto si
tenemos una base debe esto no está
diciendo que cualquier sector debe lo
podemos generar con una combinación
ideal de esos vectores entonces si yo me
tomo 1 x a 10 x a 20 por a tres más
blanda lula hasta cero por n pues
obtendría 1 y por lo tanto aquí tengo
una combinación ideal de estos vectores
que me da a 1 y entonces esto me está
diciendo que aún no existen y bueno como
aún no existen bien entonces sabemos que
podemos verlo como una combinación
lineal de estos porque estos generan el
espacio vectorial b
y entonces cómo puedo escribir a uno
como una combinación lineal de estos de
aquí estoy dándome cuenta que
precisamente esto es lo que significa
que tengamos un conjunto linealmente
dependiente es decir que al menos uno lo
podemos escribir como una combinación
lineal de todos los demás vectores y
entonces obtengo que a uno es igual a de
uno por de uno más de dos por de dos y
así hasta dm por de m donde d1 d2 de m
solamente constantes y al menos una de
estas constantes es distinta de cero
porque si todas fueran cero
entonces me quedaría que aún no sería el
vector cero y aún no no puede ser el
vector cero porque entonces no estarían
estas bases debe porque general vector 0
es muy fácil si ponemos 0 en todas las
constantes y es por eso que a uno no
puede ser el vector cero y por lo tanto
vamos a suponer que existe un dejo está
por aquí el cual es distinto de cero es
decir al menos una de estas constantes
es distinta de cero y la constante
curiosamente quedará distinta al cero
era de jota entonces por aquí tenemos al
término de j bj y ahora qué te parece si
resuelvo o si de esta expresión
bj es decir vamos a llegar a un buen de
álgebra lo que voy a hacer es pasar este
de jp j del lado izquierdo de la
ecuación con signo contrario voy a pasar
del otro lado el a1 y entonces voy a
dividir todo en 3 de jb jota vamos a
hacer los no está tan difícil aunque es
un buen de álgebra de aquí voy a
despejar a bj y bj va a ser igual a 1
entre de hecho es menos uno menos uno
entre de jota que a su vez multiplica a
todos los demás es decir a menos a uno
más de uno por b uno más de uno por b
uno más de dos por de dos más así hasta
llegar a los que estaban antes de jb
jota y después le vamos a sumar todos
los que están después de jmj así hasta
llegar a de mb n de aquí lo único que
estoy haciendo despejando a bj porque
entonces voy a poder quitar de aquí a bj
es decir podemos darnos cuenta que bj lo
podemos escribir en términos de a1 y
todos los demás vectores de conjunto b
por lo tanto vamos a prescindir de bj y
vamos a quitarlo de este conjunto
después nos va a seguir creando un
conjunto que genera
porque con todos estos vectores yo puedo
remover a bj porque ya encuentra una
combinación lineal que me la bj
es decir partir de una combinación
lineal que me daba a uno y de aquí
despeje a uno de estos vectores de los
vectores que existen en el conjunto de
uno para que así yo pueda despejar lo y
escribirlo con una combinación lineal de
todos los demás más vector a uno y con
esto lo voy a remover de este conjunto b
uno prima y no sólo eso además sigo
generando al sub espacio b como con
estos vectores puedo hacer a bj y todos
los vectores b generaban el sub espacio
b entonces también sigo generando su
espacio bien entonces hasta aquí vamos
todo bien y voy a hacer algo que tal vez
sea mucho más fácil para nosotros esto
no se hace en ningún libro sin embargo
lo voy a utilizar aquí porque va a ser
más fácil para nosotros trabajarlos de
la siguiente manera en lugar de despejar
a bj bien puede haber despejado a b1 por
lo tanto para no complicarnos la vida
mejor voy a decir que bj lo voy a pasar
al lugar de p1 y a ba1 voy a hacer que
voy a despejar es decir voy a decir que
bj es igual a b 1 y entonces veo 1 es
igual a bj
estoy haciendo es cambiando los de lugar
para que entonces en lugar de estar
despejando a bj voy a despejar a ver uno
y ya veo no es justo al vector que voy a
eliminar de este conjunto b uno prima al
final es un problema de nombres nosotros
podemos llamar a como queramos a quien
queramos entonces no nos voy a complicar
más la vida con esto y mejor voy a decir
entonces que mi nuevo conjunto lo voy a
llamar b1 b1 b de burro 1 es igual a mi
nuevo conjunto que por cierto tiene al
vector a 1 voy a quitar a b uno recuerda
que justo esto fue lo que hicimos un
cambio de bj igual a b un 9 1 a la
mejora de los cambios de lugar les
cambió el nombre y entonces en lugar de
poner a b1 voy a seguir con b 2 porque
además recuerda que podemos encontrar
una combinación lineal de estos que me
debe 1 y después pues me voy a seguir
con b3 b4 así hasta llegar a bm recuerda
que esto salió precisamente de fijarme
aquí que aún no era igual a una
combinación lineal de estos que tenía yo
aquí entonces me queda b2 b3 como así
hasta pm y bueno lo que quiero que veas
es que este conjunto también
al sub espacio 20 y eso lo sabemos
porque el conjunto de el conjunto
inicial generaba el sub espacio 20 y
está también lo va a generar porque lo
único que estoy haciendo se encontrando
otro conjunto con el cual puedo escribir
una combinación lineal que me dé b1 y
entonces tendré otra vez a mi conjunto
que generaba al sub espacio ver y bueno
usando la misma lógica ahora voy a
construir un conjunto b 2 prima este
conjunto b 2 prima va a ser igual a este
conjunto de uno pero le voy a aumentar
el vector a 2 entonces va a tener los
mismos elementos que ve uno pero también
le voy a aumentar el vector a 2 y me
quedaría pues a 1 después me quedaría a
después me quedarían b 2 después me
quedaría b 3
así hasta b m todos estos vectores hasta
llegar a bm y lo que quiero que te des
cuenta de este nuevo conjunto b 2 prima
es que como le aumente este vector a 2
entonces este es un conjunto linealmente
dependiente y es la misma razón que
utilicé para fijarme que de una primera
línea
dependiente como acabo de aumentar un
nuevo vector y además sé que todos estos
vectores generan al sub espacio ven
entonces este vector lo podemos
encontrar como una combinación lineal de
todos los demás sectores de a 192 dv3 de
todos hasta pm y por lo tanto este
conjunto es un conjunto linealmente
dependiente y bueno como es linealmente
independiente entonces de igual manera
que aquí arriba vamos a construir
nuestra combinación lineal es decir que
a 2 lo puedo ver como se uno por a 1 más
de 2 no no mejor lo voy a poner como
ceros base 2 x de 2 más de 3 x de 3 así
hasta c m por b n y de igual manera
acumuló vimos hace rato lo que quiero
que te des cuenta es que algunas de
estas constantes es distinta de 0
también cualquiera de estas constantes a
partir de ese 2 es decir se 12 3 algunas
de ellas tienen que ser distinta de 0
sin contar a la constante c 1 y esto es
muy importante porque si todas las demás
fueran 0 y solamente me quedara con que
a 2 es igual hace uno por a 1 entonces
obtendría
muy raro porque estaría construyendo a
dos como una combinación lineal de a uno
pero eso no se puede por qué porque
recuerda que tanto a uno como a dos son
elementos de mi base debe de este
conjunto a que yo tenía que arriban y
dejé no subir la pantalla para que lo
recuerdes el conjunto a que yo tenía que
arriba era una base del psuv espacio de
y por lo tanto tiene que cumplir dos
cosas la primera es que es genere al sub
espacio bien lo cual lo hace la segunda
es que es linealmente independiente y
como es linealmente independiente no
podemos ver ninguno de estos vectores
con una combinación lineal de los otros
y por lo tanto no puede quedar que a 2
sea igual a una combinación lineal que
tenga que ver con solamente a 1 es decir
se uno por a uno porque entonces no
sería linealmente independiente eso
quiere decir que debe de existir otra
constante 6 distinta de cero de las
constantes de 12 3 así hasta se me debe
de existir alguna c jmj tal que éstas cj
sea distinta de cero y ojo no
forzosamente tiene que ser la misma cj
pj que hablaba yo acá arriba
puede ser otra pero al menos sé que
existe una que es distinta de cero
porque no puede quedar solamente a dos
igual hace uno por uno y bueno ya que
tengo a esta nueva se corta bj con esta
constante cj distinta de cero que crees
que voy a hacer pues está actualmente lo
mismo que hice hace rato vamos a
despejar a bj y la idea de despejar a bj
es encontrar una combinación lineal que
media bj y la pueda remover de este
conjunto b 2 prima entonces
bj aquí me quedaría pues menos 1 / cj
que multiplica a su vez a menos a dos
más se 1 por a uno más todos los demás
hasta c m por bm y de igual manera que
hice hace rato para hacernos la vida más
fácil
voy a renombrar a ésta pj le voy a
cambiar el nombre por b 2 entonces voy a
decir que pe 2 es igual a bj y que bj es
igual a b 2
déjenme poner esto aquí abajo para que
entonces nuestra anotación sea mucho más
fácil bj es igual a b2 y b12 es igual a
mejor tan así no nos complicamos la vida
y entonces ya puedo construir un nuevo
conjunto de dos que no contenga a este
vector de dos es decir me voy a tomar
punto b 2 igual al conjunto a 1 a 2 y en
lugar de b 2 voy a poner a todos los
demás y me voy a dar cuenta que este
conjunto también genera el sub espacio
bien así que dejemos vivido aquí abajo
el nuevo conjunto que me voy a tomar es
el conjunto de dos que por cierto tiene
a los vectores a uno tiene el vector
también a dos y tiene a todos los demás
excepto a b2 es decir va a tener a b3 b4
así hasta llegar a bm así hasta llegar a
bm y ya tengo este nuevo conjunto de dos
y lo que quiero que te des cuenta es que
este conjunto de dos también genera al
sub espacio b y la forma de darme cuenta
de esto es muy parecida a como nos dimos
cuenta que el conjunto de uno genera va
a ver cómo puedo construir a b2 como una
combinación lineal de todos los demás y
además yo sé que el conjunto de uno
genera el sub espacio bien entonces este
conjunto nuevo b2 también va a generar
al sub espacio bien y bueno qué creés
voy a tomarme a un nuevo conjunto al
conjunto de tres prima y como crees que
lo voy a construir pues con los vectores
a uno
2 a 3 y voy a poner a b3 b4 así hasta bm
es decir me voy a tomar al conjunto de 2
y les voy a agregar al vector a 3 y
adivina que como b 2 generan su espacio
ven entonces este conjunto de tres prima
al agregarle este nuevo vector a 3 va a
ser linealmente dependiente y si va a
ser linealmente dependiente entonces
puedo decir que el vector a 3 lo puedo
ver como c 1 por a 1 más de 2 parados
más 3 por b 3 masas y esta se m por bm
ya que no adivinas que voy a buscar una
constante a partir de ese 3 hasta c m
que sea distinta de 0 y de igual manera
no puede ser que ese 1 y c 2 sean las
únicas constantes que sean distintas de
0 porque entonces encontraré una
combinación línea de a 1 ideados que me
diera a 3 y esto no puede ser porque
tanto a uno como a 2,3 existen en una
base b y por lo tanto tienen que ser
linealmente independientes y eso no
puede pasar entonces algunas cj de j
tiene que ser distinta de 0 y entonces
lo que voy a hacer es despejar
de nuevo a esta bj y ahora que ya tengo
el pj le voy a cambiar el nombre que sea
p3 y entonces voy a encontrar una
combinación lineal de a-1 a-2 a-3 de 4.5
así esta bm que me dé esta p 3 y por lo
tanto voy a poder construir un nuevo
conjunto llamado m3 que sea el conjunto
a 1 a 2 a 3 de 4 así hasta bm y este
conjunto que crees genera a b y sabemos
que genera b porque b 2 también generaba
20 y entonces poco a poco te estás dando
cuenta de a dónde vamos a parar aquí voy
a hacer lo mismo voy a construir de
nuevo otro conjunto llamado b 4 prima ya
este conjunto b 4 prima le voy a
aumentar un nuevo vector el vector a 4 y
es más para verlo de una manera más
general vamos a seguir nos seguimos a
seguirnos hasta que lleguemos imagínate
al conjunto de m y el conjunto bm va a
tener a los vectores a1 a2 a3
así hasta a m pero esta vez ya no va a
tener ningún vector b y usando la misma
lógica que tenemos con todos los peces
este conjunto bm va a generar al sub
espacio ve y aquí es donde ya empieza a
entrar todo el problema porque date
cuenta de una cosa nosotros habíamos
dicho que venía en elementos pero m era
menor que en él esto es bastante
importante y por otra parte nosotros
habíamos empezado con algo muy
importante con un conjunto a el cual era
una base debe de apuntar aquí a mi
conjunto a el conjunto am era igual al
conjunto de vectores a-1 a-2 a-3 así
hasta llegar a la m y de aquí podremos
pasar a m más 1 es que aquí no sé
cuántos lectores más tenga que los
vectores de eventos mejor vamos a
ponerlo archivo hasta a n tengo aquí a
mi conjunto am el cual tiene más
vectores que el conjunto b m porque n
era más grande que me menorquines estas
dos cosas es lo mismo pero yo sé que mi
conjunto am es una base del psuv espacio
ven esta era una base del psuv espacio
ven y entonces si es una base de su
espacio 20 hay que pasar dos cosas la
primera es que genera
que sea linealmente independiente pero
me acaba de encontrar a otro conjunto de
m que tiene menos vectores y que también
generan sub espacio y por lo tanto estoy
diciendo que todos estos vectores a1 a2
así hasta m generan al psuv espacio b y
si generará sub espacio bien generan a
todos los vectores que existen en el sub
espacio b y esto quiere decir que
entonces puedo encontrar una combinación
lineal de esos vectores que me dé a n
pero si no encuentra una combinación
lineal de estos vectores que me dé jaén
pues yo sé que a n existe en este sub
espacio b entonces estoy diciendo que
este conjunto a es linealmente
dependiente y que es esto que está
sucediendo
por una parte tengo que linealmente
independiente por otra parte tengo que
finalmente dependiente pues esto no
puede ser por lo tanto es una
contradicción estoy llegando a dos
resultados contradictorios que a su vez
digo que son verdaderos y porque llegué
a esta contradicción bueno porque estoy
suponiendo que existe un conjunto con
una carnalidad menor que am que genera
el sub espacio b y eso no puede ser y
entonces es justo cuando concluyó lo que
yo quería
es decir que no puede existir otro
conjunto que generaba que tenga menos
elementos que no puede existir un
conjunto que genere a su vez al sub
espacio vez que tenga menos elementos
que el conjunto am
que por cierto recuerda que es una base
de el sub espacio b por lo tanto ya
llegué a lo que quería de mostrarte este
vídeo y esto me sirve bastante porque tú
imagínate que tú tienes un conjunto x
que genera al sub espacio b entonces
vamos a tener un conjunto x que genere
al sub espacio b y bueno este conjunto x
si genera su espacio bien y supongamos
que tiene no sé cinco elementos y
después nos damos cuenta que este
conjunto es linealmente independiente
entonces podemos decir que x es una base
debe entonces era ponerlo aquí x es una
base del psuv espacio b y bueno ahora
imagínate que por otra parte encontramos
a otra base
de este mismo sube espacio ve
encontramos allí otra base de este sub
espacio entonces cómo escribirlo aquí
bien es otra base del psuv espacio ven y
entonces en este momento podemos
concluir que sigue es también base del
psuv espacio bien pues entonces llegue
debe de tener cinco elementos y como sé
que ya debe de tener cinco elementos
bueno porque nosotros nos fijamos en la
carne alidad que nos dice el resultado
que acabamos de obtener primero nos dice
que como x es una base debe y tiene
cinco elementos sabemos que tiene cinco
elementos entonces por este resultado
sabemos que ya tiene una cantidad de
elementos mayor o igual que 5 que son
los elementos que tiene x pero también
sabemos y también lo podemos escribir de
la siguiente manera también sabemos que
ya es una base debe por lo tanto x debe
tener una cantidad mayor o igual de los
elementos que tiene james y eso mejor lo
puedo escribir de la siguiente manera
los elementos de james los elementos de
james y mejor déjenme escribirlos y creo
que me sirve más escribirlo así
los elementos de los elementos de james
tiene que ser mayor o igual que los
elementos de x o la calidad de x esto lo
sabemos por el resultado que acabamos de
obtener entonces los elementos de james
tiene que ser mayor o igual que la
cantidad de elementos que tiene x sin
embargo y es una base del psuv espacio y
por lo tanto en la cantidad de elementos
de x tiene que ser mayor o igual que la
cantidad de elementos que tiene el
conjunto y en estos por el mismo
razonamiento y entonces queda atrapada
la cantidad de elementos que tienen por
una parte tienen que ser mayor o igual
que la cantidad de elementos que tiene x
y por otra parte tiene que ser menor o
igual que la cantidad de elementos que
tiene x y aquí no queda de otra estamos
diciendo que la cantidad de elementos
que tiene x es igual a la cantidad de
elementos que tiene bien la carnalidad
de x forzosamente tiene que ser igual a
la cardinal y that de bien pero bueno
regresemos a nuestro conjunto a nuestro
conjunto a que era una base de este sub
espacio b tiene en elementos y entonces
acabo de ver que cualquier otra
base que yo me tomé de este suv o
espacio bien debe de tener en elementos
y entonces como todas las bases tienen
la misma cantidad de elementos
yo puedo definir la dimensión del sub
espacio bem y esta definición es bien
importante bien padre la dimensión de
ven como la cantidad de elementos que
tienen una base de bem es decir la
cardinal y that de una de las bases
deben y es que como ya sé que todas las
bases tienen la misma cantidad de
elementos entonces la dimensión debe
estar perfectamente bien definida si una
base tiene cinco elementos la otra base
tiene seis ya podemos asegurar que algo
está mal o es 5 o 6 no hay de otra por
lo tanto ya tenemos la definición de la
dimensión de ve como el número de
elementos de una de las bases debe